my favorite chili burger story is we
were at the comedy store like mm okay
and man Jody is with the only one
smoking weed okay up there they're a
bunch of lame-o's in just wasn't in me
and Coco were it and we kept on getting
the ear beating from this black guy who
said he was a producer from Fox he was
just doing this to come into the shows
he probably wasn't even a PA a
production assistant you know this guy
was there and he was so [ __ ] annoyed
and telling us about what TV show we
should do and stuff like this and Coco I
guess he had a head called and the
boogers the boogers he was pulling out
Lee they were they were like hard as the
at the beginning and then like really
sick and wet at the end I've seen ok you
know what I'm talking about just those
those theramin it's like half Triscuit
half snail okay and he'd take those and
and he goes to the sky and like him
rubberman okay that guy must have had
20,000 snots on the back of his jacket
by the end of the night Coco I saw this
one too late
he got one going on one finger all right
and then went was the other nostril with
the Sun with the thumb all right and so
he had to and that one that one looked
like a [ __ ] seagull [ __ ] on that
guy's shoulder it was so sick and it was
amazing and this guy was such a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it was the most tremendous to put snot
on my high school teacher mr. Zink oh
yeah I was a daughter you can wear the
same black jacket every and once or
twice a week ago come and tap on the
shoulder say what I'm mr. Zink his back
has [ __ ] thousands a little right and
I never watched a jacket it was there it
was smart Tom who off right but
is not a few people but that guy the
producer was the [ __ ] best and then
that was the best man there's so many
charlatans I came to school a little
mini